I don't know how you do it Peter King I
don't how you do it on deadline I don't
know how you're you pop all that stuff
out like that it's it's amazing and now
you're back at wqi con the Rich Eisen
show how are you Peter hey rich well
when you've done something like that for
20 years you kind of get the hang of it
I say the same thing about I might say
the same thing about you and and all the
all the wickets that you you know occupy
every week so I'm I was really I was
really really happy that you wrote that
in part I mean I don't know if any
anybody out here recalls precisely how
you did that column they should but what
was really cool about it is that you
took us into the the meeting that the
that al River Ron had with all of the
NFL Network family and nfl.com family in
California a few weeks ago and I thought
it was really really interesting because
I think you raised a question that is at
the heart of the pass interference
dilemma as we move into at least a
one-year period because I'm not sure
it's going to last any longer than one
year honestly we are going to have a
one-year experimental period where pass
interference both called and non called
for the first 28 minutes of each half is
going to be eligible to the you know for
coaches challenges and as you wrote very
very well and insightfully that when
river on would put up clays on the on
the big screen that you know some people
in the room foot yeah interference no I
wasn't interfering so that's what is
going to have to be determined when they
go to replay review well the issue Peter
is that that the you know there's always
the if you will unintended consequence
the intended
yeah the intention for this rule was to
create a safety net that will prevent
the NFC Championship game from ever
happening again and I totally agreed
with that and I think it it's necessary
to weave that safety net after what we
saw last year
but the unintended consequence is just
like anything else that's reviewable
once the review process starts anything
that is allowed to be reviewed is in
fact reviewed you know in the process so
that means every time you know that
you're looking for offensive pass
interference because a booth is buzzed
in or a flag has been thrown for it
defensive pass interference is now gonna
be looked at as well and vice versa and
I'm thinking that that might be the
tweak here Peter is that understanding
that every time you open up replay
everything that's reviewable can be
reviewed
maybe we exempt pass interference from
that category otherwise you might get
offsetting penalties every damn time and
it's going to be really upsetting and
confusing to a lot of fans look I asked
our River on directly rich are you
worried about a spate of offsetting
penalties right because essentially you
know I think if you examine replay and I
had listened rich over the weekend I'm
just telling you this was this was what
because I asked a bunch of people what
are the things you're worried about was
this and listened to the response of one
coach you said listen I just wanna I
want to raise this point that we've been
talking about and that is that what
happens when away from the play maybe
not all the way across the field but
what happens if in the slot after a
winning touchdown is scored right at the
end of a game and they even go to booth
review okay what happens if the slot
receiver let's see we you know the tight
end is in the slot okay and he pushes
off the safety
clearly pushes off when the ball is in
the air and so and but it had nothing to
do with the play what are they going to
do and you know that is going to be a
big big test because if you are going to
call pass interference by the letter of
the law you
supposed to call pass interference even
if it is not with the two guys where the
ball is intended for so that's going to
be another issue here yeah I think that
this this may be something similar Peter
to if you remember a couple years ago
that the way that in the first year
after Dean Blandino had left in our
River on the new still ahead of NFL refs
came in that replay looked at whether it
was catch not a catch in a way that was
different than way Blandino would call
it like basically they're gonna stay
with the ruling on the field ninety-nine
out of a hundred times but instead they
started Zapruder filming this thing was
the ball moving a little bit let's be
totally literal about it let's parse it
out and if you remember Kelvin Benjamin
had a touchdown in New England for the
bills callback that was what that was
the worst call in the history replay
right and then they chinos they
basically changed the way that they
reviewed it and for the playoffs and
that came into being for a touchdown for
the Eagles you know where Clement caught
one were kind of juggling and right in
the end zone they and obviously the Zach
Ertz plays to that they definitely
change the way they reviewed it maybe
and they did the same thing with passer
roughing the passer last year maybe they
have a similar epiphany midseason this
year even though it's not the best idea
to go about it that way doesn't have you
saw what happened you saw what happened
last year when during the preseason and
I forget the numbers on this but there
was I bet there were fifty or sixty you
know leading with the crown of the
helmet right you know calls made and we
all thought everybody's hands were
ringing from coast coast to coast but
how can you play football like this blah
blah blah and the season started they
never called it that's right you know it
was they cried wolf the officiating
department cried wolf on that last year
I asked River on about that too and he
said no no no players learned and they
were good and there's no question that
players were better but by the letter of
the law they missed 50 of those calls
last year and all of which were called
in the preseason so again I have no idea
how this is going to be called but this
just strikes me rich let's fast-forward
to the league meetings in Florida late
next March and I don't know where
there'll be Orlando Palm Beach somewhere
but let's fast-forward to those can you
get 24 of the 32 NFL owners to agree
that this replay thing was a good idea
you know with pass interference now
we'll see there's a lot of things that
can happen and will happen between now
and then but I'll just say this I think
of all these things that have ever been
passed is one year experiments more than
any of them because replay back in the
90s and and even more recently was
passed as a one year experiment with
different things and in my opinion this
is the one that is the most endangered
of those species that I think after one
year this has a good chance to disappear
Peter King here on the Rich Eisen show
and the instant replay for pass
interference part of your return to the
keyboard that was on NBC sports.com
today right here on the Rich Eisen show
okay the collective bargaining agreement
what do you think here I mean this is
they got a couple more years left and
I'm sure Roger Goodell would love to
present to the fan base to kick off an
NFL 100 season a completed collective
bargaining agreement what do you think
the odds are that happening
well Goodell told CNBC recently that
it's his Hulk that there's a new CBA in
place before the start of the 2019
season I think that's a absolute pipe
dream hey good for them but if the if
the NFL is going to have a new deal with
the players their fourth negotiating
session between the NFL Management
Council and the NFL pas 10-member
Executive Committee begins on Wednesday
of this week it's a three-day session so
who knows they may get serious but you
know to this point there's been nothing
major put on the table
you know we're seven weeks from the
start of the regular season I don't know
how you get a deal of that magnitude
done in seven weeks I hope it's done so
it's not hanging over the head of the
game like a sort of Damocles but you
know I was told on Saturday that there
has been zero discussion yet of
percentage of the gross that's what this
is going to come down to rich you know
we can talk about Oh what are they going
to do with the preseason what are they
going to do with putting a team in
London all these other things that's all
window dressing the fact is the biggest
thing for the players is going to be
what even do about percentage of the
gross and I think it was very
interesting the Green Bay Packers this
week or last week basically no issue
there you know their earnings report and
basically their player costs during that
the average team player costs with
salary cap and benefits last year was
about 215 220 million dollars per team
and you know the league wrote every team
a check for about 275 million last year
so that doesn't even include the you
know anything else there's you know any
local revenue your local TV or radio
revenue which teams can keep and and and
and and all the other ticket revenue and
things like there so you know look I
think that players if you start talking
about 5050 one maybe even fifty two
percent of the gross then we're talking
about a way that a deal can get done
before the start of the season I doubt
sincerely that the owners until they're
kicking and screaming will ever be
dragged to give the players that much
say 51 or 52 percent well I mean there's
the issue of an 18-game season that's
being thrown out there Peter huh how
real is this is it something that I
don't think it's very real at all rich
because I was told over the weekend that
there are two or three there one or two
teams rather one or two as I visit exact
words that I was told
are interested in this proposal an
18-game season with players playing a
maximum of 16 games and look I have made
this point for the last three or four
years the only way I would ever support
an 18-game schedule or the only way I
think teams ever should support it is
that the players would play maybe except
for a long snapper
a pun or a kicker not to demean the
physical demands that they have but
they're just not involved in as many
plays and as many physical plays as say
a corner or wide receiver a quarterback
but but the only way they'd have a
chance is to do it that way and the
reason I just don't see it happening is
that you know right now last year rich
this was pointed out to me there were 60
starting quarterback games missed last
year and that suppose that the number
was a hundred and eleven in 2017 the NFL
was deliriously happy with that number
that's 60 that number 60 which means
that it's about the healthiest the
quarterback starting quarterbacks have
ever gotten through a regular season why
risk either elongating the season or
making the season any different even if
you're going to say that starting
quarterbacks can only play 16 games I
just don't think it's a formula the NFL
the majority of teams in the NFL and
owners in the NFL want to fool with
right now and you've got some teams we
know it that doesn't matter what it is
if they can make them more money they'll
put gorillas out there they'll put
giraffes out there they don't care they
just they want the two extra weeks on TV
but my point has always been you know
the NFL is wringing its hands over head
trauma and and over you know concussions
and you know if you ever if you ever let
players play 18 weeks play 18 games no
matter how many buys you give them or
whatever all of that all that emphasis
about head trauma and concern about
concussions it's laughable you know it
just proves that all they're concerned
about is money
rather than you know the the health of
their players few more minutes left with
Peter King football morning in America
column latest one out here on the Rich
Eisen show you hit the Melvin Gordon
contractual impasse how do you see that
playing out right now you know I don't
know I think if I think lately players
have had a lot of willpower when it
comes to hold outs you so obviously what
happened to Le'Veon Bell and I have no
idea deep down you know it could be that
Melvin Gordon has said hey I'm gonna
take this all the way to the wall if
they don't pay me twelve million
thirteen million a year guaranteed I'm
not playing
well then if he's going to do that then
he's gonna have a long time where he's
not gonna play in probably the entire
year but you know he made a statement
over the weekend that basically it's
been proven that running backs are so
valuable and we can't be replaced
or it's hard to replace us and
everything and I don't know what game
he's watching you know CJ Anderson you
know ran for whatever 307 yards 380
yards in the first four weeks where he
came off his couch to to replace Todd
Gurley and and it at James Connor last
year one of the best backs in the league
replacing Le'Veon Bell and look Le'Veon
Bell is a special special talent Melvin
Gordon is a is a great talent I get it
but you know if if you told the scene
the Los Angeles chargers right now that
you're going to war this year with
Austin Eckler and CJ Anderson or whoever
else it's going to be behind him if you
told them I don't think they would they
wouldn't they want Melvin Gordon but I
don't think they they'd be they'd be
crying about that so I started the show
Peter by saying that from Jerry Jones I
signed deckhand Zeke before the season
figure out what you could do with the
Maury Cooper when I have to do I mean
because I would do but rich I see I
think the problem with that and I mean
everybody I wrote last year is you just
have to face facts you're going to have
to pay that Prescott
28 to 30 million a year yes that's it
that's it you just do he just
you shouldn't wring your hands about it
or or say how ridiculous it is
you should just pay them your
quarterback is going to get paid that
much correct and if you're gonna pay if
you're going to pay your quarterback
let's say 15 percent of your salary cap
14 or 15 percent on average over the
next five years I mean just go back to
when you know all teams other than New
England have won a Super Bowl the vast
majority have won them with quarterbacks
making a big chunk of the salary cap and
so I just think it's not that big a deal
now Ezekiel Elliott I mean that's a
tough call I guess I would pay him but
the road is littered with running backs
who got paid and it wasn't a good idea
now Zeke is so young he still has so
much tread on his tire you say the same
thing for Melvin Gordon but I think as
Eagle Elliott is is a better player than
Melvin Gordon is well you've been on you
even you've been at it a while Peter is
there ever been a contract where you get
paid if you're in if you stay at home
and and you don't leave the house after
9 o'clock at night can you put that in a
contract for someone like Elliot because
they you know like that that we I know I
know but but but you know what you have
to do with that contract you just have
to write some insurance policies in that
contract that's all there is to it right
you know he's he's too much of a wild
card to I would you know the way you do
this contract rich is very simple in my
opinion you say hey look if the Hillel
Elliot you know plays 14 or more games
in each year of this contract you know
he's eligible for the following
guarantees and you know not injury
related you know he because if you get
hurt playing football you deserve to get
your money but in all other ways if
Ezekiel Elliott is not there and not
available you shouldn't have to pay him
exactly because you know let's be honest
as well your Peter I mean what you just
said about Melvin Gordon just tying it
all together here is
that that you could you could do without
your star you can make make do you can
still I mean they were for know without
Melvin Gordon last year here in Los
Angeles yes they were able to accomplish
all together defensively offensively but
you could make the case that Zeke is
kind of exempt from that I mean he is
that difference maker for the Dallas
Cowboys I mean they need him I think we
need him I think right now his I you
know I I have to just say this there
aren't I really really enjoy watching
Le'Veon Bell play he's uh he's a maestro
of the running back position I hope he
still is for the Jets I think he's he's
incredibly fun to watch so I hope I hope
the fans get to see that for several
more years I don't know if you will but
I hope you will and other than that as
far as a power versatile running back
Ezekiel Elliott is such a treat to watch
in he is a smart running back several
times last year they're trying to run
the clock out and he burrows his way
back in so to make sure that he doesn't
he doesn't go out of bounds he's just
he's smart he he's capable of carrying a
team on his shoulders
he's he's he's Earl Campbell I think and
I you know and I really really like them
but I mean I just think the Cowboys in
look at the Cowboys rich they've got so
many people they have to pay you know
they've got to pay a receiver who are
they going to pay at linebacker what are
you gonna do with Jaylin Smith I mean
you know what do you in today there's
just a lot of guys on this team you've
paid the Marcus Lawrence and you know
the it's been shown over the years that
it's very hard to pay three to four
players on your team at the absolute top
of their earnings at their position and
have enough to be really competitive
beyond that so I understand I I think
Jerry would love to pay him all but I
understand why he might drive a very
very hard bargain he and Steven Jones
going forward in the next few weeks
Peter appreciate the call thanks for the
call
we'll chat again soon really that's a
rich and thanks a lot for for giving me
a nice week off this summer and happened
thanks Peter same to you will Chad CC
intent I assume that's Peter king at
Peter underscore king for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app